it is a staggering number hundreds of
people died by suicide in Clark County
over the past five years during the
pandemic the number especially high for
teens alarming both parents and experts
and now it's teens who want to get the
message out there's help Joshua piguero
explains Luca Fang a junior at Coronado
High School is leading an effort to
highlight Teen Mental Health by
organizing a rainbow run we're trying to
address the vulnerability aspect of
mental health and talking about it as so
as participants run along the Route
they'll be able to answer questions
prompted along the Route such as Who Do
You Love suicide is the second leading
cause of teen deaths in the silver state
that's really the worst message you can
tell someone is that they're not feeling
those feelings and they should just
change how they're feeling right away in
2018 22 of those who died by Suicide
were under the age of 20. the following
year it decreased but then during the
pandemic the numbers spiked to 27. since
then youth suicides in Clark County have
gone down slightly the total number of
all suicides in 2022 was 484 and the gun
was the cause of death in more than half
of the suicides since 2018. if you are
going through a mental health crisis
know that there are several
organizations in the Las Vegas Valley
that could help you one of them is right
behind us it's the National Alliance of
mental illness the Coronado hope Squad
students engaged in peer-to-peer
mentoring and it's been an eye-opening
experience for them feeling really
disconnected you're supposed to feel
safe at home and they really weren't so
it's like if I can't feel safe at school
and I can't feel safe at home what am I
supposed to do so they were feeling
really helpless the walk will take place
on Saturday April 1st around Cornerstone
Park in Henderson Joshua peguero eight
news now
if you're struggling with a mental
health crisis please call or text the
suicide and crisis hotline at 988 also
tonight at the Las Vegas city hall there
will be a town hall on suicide
prevention that begins at 5 30 this
evening